foreign
[Music]
I've found something
I've looked at it from Every Which Way I
Am the smartest person I ever met and I
can't figure it out so I came to the
second you are up to something my friend
I've seen the million is so called
psychic you want to fake
I do not believe it psychics
spot the con I can't
detective you are here to discredit me
but I can talk to the Dead
if all I have to hear my daughter's
voice
wants to be heard we are here listening
um
Felicia
what is happening
[Applause]
[Music]
your contract is here somebody is dead
want to leave this place until I know
who did it a ghost killed her
there must be our rational answer for
all of this
just admit that you are up against
something bigger than you no
[Music]
you were saying
something in this house tried to kill me
don't look at me like I'm suspect we're
old friends
every murderer is somebody's old friends
no one shall leave until I find if the
living have been killed by the Dead
you have been hiding here all this time
who are you talking to
[Music]
thank you